Lisa hi hi I'm a great thing but you
just don't put together you just looked
at I look at you having a good time out
now like um my leaf still not wearing
earrings
hey Lisa can you loan her spirit oh yeah
yeah I brought a few pairs well actually
those those are my earrings that she's
wearing that fits right Ken
has she returned them to me a long time
ago Lisa Lisa
I've taken pictures of right now just
want to get the moment King that person
oh no you're really cute can you believe
that Moses he's that wood posted it's
already done it's already done something
I just had this assumption because
Kappas is those people look at me yeah
that there can you stop throwing your
hair what do I look like a trash person
like I look like a trash can look your
hair in that picture yes I do do you do
you can you delete it I feel like you're
just like that's making me feel some
type of way cause you know I'm
transitioning right now I'm gonna report
your page yes you're thinking cute it's
factual oh my god I can't help it
ready uh yeah do you mind if maybe I
just tried this on
yes so it writers you look good in it
really yeah you like princess Lisa just
come out this thing just come out I will
you know how I am to be cautious there's
nobody you never know
that's how you hit a kid can you just
can you just pick something I'm trying
to get to something good
you were dating that boy no yes you were
no not at all yes you were you were
close we were close friends I was not
dating him I saw you kiss him no yes I
did no you're making that up
nice can you take it up just me my gosh
you're so cliche
I'm visiting oh hey this is a vacation
BYE MOM thank you okay five dollars you
can always move back move in with your
sister oh no oh no no no yeah wait he
could my jacket Lisa give me back my
jacket
the daughter is about to die I'm telling
you right now